RETO MEIER: As developers,
we spend most of our time
staring at our IDE, so we
care a lot about our tools.
I'm Reto Meier, this is
Android Tool Time time,
and this is Android Studio 1.5.
Android Studio 1.5
includes a number
of bug fixes and enhancements
that includes an upgrade
to the memory profiler.
This new analysis
feature can analyze
a heap dump to look
for known problems,
such as leaked activities.
To use this feature,
open a heap dump and look
for the Analyze the Tasks
window on the right.
In the analysis window, you
can press the Run button
to perform an analysis, and
then drill into the results.
Here's an example of
a leaked activity.
There are several
new link checks, too.
Here's one which
warns you if you're
intending to override resources
referenced from the manifest.
Hmm, the rest of this
looks like bug fixes.
Hide module selector when only
one module in theme editor.
Correct title set for
creating new module
in New Module Wizard.
Provide documentation and XML
attribute values completion.
This can't be right.
Jamal?
JAMAL: Yes?
RETO MEIER: Is that right,
or did I miss something?
It seems just like a bunch
of stability improvements
and some bug fixes.
JAMAL: Basically, it's
a lot of good bug fixes.
RETO MEIER: OK,
but, you know, this
is my first What's New
in Android Studio video.
So I was kind of hoping to
make a big splash, you know?
JAMAL: Look, I understand
that, but these
are very important bug fixes.
RETO MEIER: I guess.
Ooh, what about this box?
Can I tell them
what's in the box?
JAMAL: No.
We can't talk about the box.
RETO MEIER: Are you sure?
It looks pretty interesting.
JAMAL: Look, Reto,
we can definitely not
talk about the box.
Why is it even here?
We should really
focus on the bugs.
RETO MEIER: OK.
Well, the Theme Editor
now has a preview
of the theme that's
about to be created.
There's a number of bug fixes
in the editor area, where we've
been working hard to
polish code completion
for resource and manifest files.
For example, you can
now use short names
when doing code completion
for custom views.
We also made sure that Android
Studio doesn't steal your focus
if you switch virtual desktops
during the build and run phase.
Download Android Studio 1.5 now
for these and many other bug
fixes and stability
improvements.
That's Android Studio 1.5.
This is Android Tool Time,
and you should totally forget
I said anything about the box.
Seriously, I shouldn't
have mentioned it.
JAMAL: Stop talking
about the box!
[MUSIC PLAYING]